best baseball movie of all time that's a
bad question for me not a big movie guy
I mean baseball I think like bul
Durham's up there for me I like Money
Ball probably Bull Durham what's the
most memorable thing that anyone's ever
yelled from the stands at you I don't
know it's probably coming up this
serious favorite sports team besides
your own ooh big Seahawks fan probably a
Seahawks now with the right pitch how
far could you hit a whiffle ball from
home plate big holes or small holes
let's go big holes with the baseball bat
or whiffle ball bat which one do you
think you'd be better with I think
whiffle ball bat I'll go 220 ft and
what's your favorite City to play in
besides your own I like Pittsburgh a lot
we went there this year and I enjoyed
Pittsburgh a hobby that you wish you had
more time to do right now a cook I like
seafood but can't go wrong with good
steak either and lastly who do you
think's the most exciting player in the
MLB right now most exciting I think sh
but auni is up there too I'd say between
those two